one of my favorite people i've gotten to
meet here in los angeles and he's also
uh
the goat um the voice of sunday night
football and also 18 years ago the voice
of one of the greatest performances in
the history of monday night football
when brett favre 18 years ago tonight
torched the oakland raiders with the
proverbial and literal heavy heart
because his father just passed away the
great al michaels here on the rich eisen
show on the mercedes-benz vans phone
line how are you al michaels
i'm great rich man what a memory
that is and was oh right 18 years ago
hard to believe but uh
i remember everything about it it was uh
obviously uh
an emotional night a crazy night
and
the day before rich we
you know always have our production
meetings so i think the packers had come
into
the bay area on saturday so we're
meeting with the packers on sunday in
the early afternoon
they're staying at the claremont resort
in berkeley
so brett comes into the meeting it's
about i guess one o'clock in the
afternoon
and brett was great in those meetings i
mean he was very expansive in fact
occasionally he was so expensive that
you would begin to drift off a little
bit
so he comes in he's sitting at the head
of the table
i'm sitting off to his left and i'm
looking out a
circular window that gives me a shot all
the way across the bay
of the golden gate bridge way out in the
distance it's a beautiful afternoon
and brett's going on and on and you know
brett was so aware of what was going on
he could read the room extremely well
and he looks at me and he says don't
doze off on me
no no i said brett listen i said you
have to understand something i am look
i'm looking at your profile and beyond
your profile
is the golden gate bridge so i've got
two american icons
in my view uh right now so
we laughed about that anyway the what i
remember about that meeting
is when brett ended it
he said he and doug peterson
who was the backup quarterback and of
course the coach the eagles to the
super bowl championship four years ago
he and doug were going going to go to a
very
close by
public golf course
and play nine holes
and so there they were the day before
the game the two quarterbacks they join
up with a couple of guys who are just
you know have signed up for to play no
way
yes and
yes
and doug has a cell phone
in his golf bag
and it rang
and he picked it up
and it was diana farve
saying that brett's father had died and
that is how brett got the word now we
didn't know any of this
until uh until later on because the next
day when we got up and had our
production meeting uh
back in san francisco
the uh the word was that brett was not
going to play
and then we got word that he was going
to going to try to play
and of course we all know what happened
that night 399 yards
i think 31-7 was the half-time score
uh you had robert ferguson and donald
driver and i think javon walker
had fabulous nights and what i remember
about that game too rich is that
everything
he'd throw something up in the air it
looked like it couldn't be caught and it
was caught
it was like he was ordained that any
time brett threw a pass somebody was
gonna somebody was gonna get it so that
was
the night of nights we had all these you
know shots of a bread on the bench and
you know what it's like i mean you lose
a parent and especially in these
circumstances and every once in a while
you'd see brett on the bench and he was
having a sinking spell
and he had a number of them but then
come back on the field and of course
that was uh
one of the all-time nfl classic games as
far as i'm concerned yeah michael's here
on the rich eisen show and so what
how do you handle it i mean obviously
you've been there and done that with so
many other emotional moments in your uh
announcing career but uh you're you
you're realizing in front of you
what what is happening and how that must
be resonating with an audience at home
um
what what about you in the moment
realizing what was happening
well i know that when john madden and i
uh came on the air and i think one of
the first questions i asked john is
what do you expect tonight i mean and
and john said something along the lines
that we you know we don't know nobody's
really ever been here
in this particular circumstance i mean
guys have played when
you know a parent or a sibling has died
but under this particular circumstance
a high-profile quarterback who just
found out about his father
you know dying suddenly in his 50s the
day before and obviously he was so close
to
the ur farm
nobody knew nobody knew what was going
to happen but one of the things about
television rich is that people can see
what's going on
you don't have to embellish it you don't
have to uh speculate as to what he might
be thinking in these particular
situations
uh
you know these are this is a case of
again you know the old cliche but a
picture
uh
tells a thousand words it's it's better
than a thousand words sometimes
people could see it and you didn't have
to as i say uh make it any more than it
was that that people could see i mean we
all knew
john and i and and the millions of
people who were watching it this was
this was just extraordinary
and you let it play out and let people
have their own thoughts about it
and uh but you know but don't don't try
to go so deep into this just
talk about you know
the fact it is unprecedented it's almost
as if the other players
i don't want to say they played better
that night but rich i mean there's some
passages that normally would not be
caught that were caught
so i don't know if it gave the the other
guys you know the walkers and the
drivers and and people like that and
amon green ran for 137 yards i think was
the number that night
uh
i think everybody else on that team
ratcheted up their game that night for
brett now michael's here on the rich
eisen show um outside of that what what
it was it like going to and calling a
game in the black hole with john madden
what was that like it was cool i mean it
really was i mean john was uh of course
an iconic figure back then and
that year the raiders were were not very
good they had
won the uh
conference the year before had been
blown out by tampa bay in the super bowl
and i think they were i don't know four
and ten or something like that one four
and i went when they went into that game
so they were out of it it was one of
those games and this is you know pre
pre-flex schedule
where uh that game might you might have
flexed out of that game right had we had
the flex availability at that particular
point but we didn't so we were locked
into it because you had you know green
bay on their way to the playoffs and the
raiders on their way to nowhere so it
was one of those things where you know
it was locked in
uh did a couple of games with john over
the years in the uh
in the black hole it was fun it was
always a lot of fun to uh to go in there
even though you know that stadium was uh
next thing well i i wouldn't say the
worst because candlestick park gets my
uh voters the worst but this was this
was a a very close runner up well i mean
and you also had moments there too right
i mean call them baseball games
i did well i did well i did two world
series one in 1972 and i was the reg
announcer yeah and we played the the a's
and then the earthquake world series of
course the first two games were in
oakland
and then we went back to san francisco
to candlestick park for a game three
which uh had the earthquake
at 504
and then a 10-day delay before we picked
that one up in the and the a's won it so
yeah i've done
a number of games in the oakland
coliseum and uh it's the uh
long gone not to be lamented oakland
coliseum
well i always remember it was a dub it
was a dub well i remember i remember
doing thursday night games there uh for
many many many years and i remember
going out to the um
to the turf and the the tunnel
underneath would have like the warning
track dirt they would have the mound
dirt they would just be different and
then rocks that they you know like they
would have piles of different
various forms of baseball necessity
uh dirt
that they would not ha you know that and
then they'd turn into a football stadium
it was just i've never seen anything
like it there's just nothing else rich
what about the cockroaches and the
tarantulas
and
of insects i mean i mean it was an
etymologist's dream under there
and it stunk too as you as you know no
that was that was built you know it was
built in the 60s and yeah you try to
keep it up a little bit and have it and
i mean it's it's just amazing to me that
these are still playing there that's
true that's your al michael's here on
the rich house have you spoken to brett
about this night since then at any point
in time whenever the two of you guys
yeah through the years yes not not
recently though but right we were in uh
in green bay when they you know put
brett's name up on the ring of honor in
a thanksgiving game a few years back we
brought him into the booth in fact and
and we talked to him so yes
over the years we we went back and
and talked about that night and you know
how surreal it was i mean that was the
only way you could you could put it i
mean
with all that was going on you know
finding out and as i say it's it's an
amazing story that he finds out on a
golf course
because doug peterson happens to have a
cell phone in his golf bag
and then you know and then his wife flew
out
uh
to be with him
and i think that you know as i say that
morning we were getting word
from the packers that uh it was likely
that he would not play
and that doug would play and then uh
like it was an early game because it was
a west coast start so right game started
at around six o'clock but uh we heard it
around three or so and as we were as we
headed to the stadium
that it was likely that he would play so
again you know came on the air and john
said uh don't know haven't been here
don't know this is unprecedented
18 years ago tonight al michael's here
on the rich island show recalling all
that all right so the here and now
you're going to dallas for this big game
on sunday
that uh that dallas can clinch the
division with a dub uh washington
hopefully will be healthy literally um
and and play this game uh
and and it's just fascinating to me how
things change obviously in a football
season
the dallas defense is clearly the the
unit that is carrying the cowboys right
now as opposed to the offensive side of
the ball when you saw them on the first
thursday night of the season dax thrown
for 400 yards and things like that it's
amazing how uh things have kind of
switched a little bit don't you think no
question i mean dan quinn obviously has
done a great job and i'm sure that uh
he'll be looked at to to come back as
the head coach for somebody maybe as
early as next year i think that
the other thing too rich is that it's
been kind of a crazy season for these
guys we had their game uh halloween
night in minnesota that's right
and cooper rush
comes in and wins the game of course
with some help from from that defense as
well and i think right now as you look
at it you know only one team gets a bye
at the moment it would be green bay
dallas is in a position to maybe get the
number two
seed
if they are i mean not only do you get a
a wild card home game you could get a
divisional home game as well
so i mean that two seat is big the one
of course is gigantic because you get
the bye week and you rest up and
and everything comes through your
stadium and they're they're not out of
the mix for that either right now
because you know they've got washington
they'll be favored this week
i think arizona goes in there that's
going to be a really interesting game uh
the following week
and you know the cowboys
it's funny and you're right i mean early
on
prescott an opening night looked great
you know took tampa bay down to the wire
dak was probably in the mvp conversation
for five or six weeks
uh then he had the injury missed the
game and all of that and and obviously
hasn't played all that well uh and they
don't look like a super team right now
except for the for the defense and
they've got lawrence back and and and
playing well and you know dave has 10
interceptions they're taking the ball
away so uh and you know and they should
beat washington whether washington's
healthy or not on sunday night at least
they'll be uh strongly favored i think
so uh here we go again the dallas
cowboys you know you and i have talked
about this through the years
every year it doesn't matter
there's so much interest in that team
and everybody you know laughs and and
mocks the fact you know some still
called them america's team which you
know tech stream called them many many
years ago but in a way
uh
people are interested in the cowboys and
it's one of those teams i've always said
they're like the yankees
you love them or hate them but you can't
ignore them
and number two seed owl is a
obviously
you you don't get the the week off but
that's
second best literally and also
figuratively because
you're going to be facing a team that's
most likely eight uh you know nine and
eight if not eight and nine coming in
as opposed to the three and four seed
where you're probably gonna face
you know either the second or third
place team
in the uh
in the nfc west right i mean that and
the one team that you know you saw on on
a sunday night a dreadful rainy sunday
night when the colts
came in to take on san francisco that
was kind of the last game
in which the niners didn't have shades
of 2019 they have come
from a long way huge strikes
as the proverb and both of those teams
colts and niners you could say are the
proverbial teams you don't want to face
in either conference
going into it yeah right now i mean the
the niners i thought
they looked like they were dead i mean
they had all those injuries as well
you didn't know what garoppolo was going
to do the rest of the season would they
move lance in there kittle gets hurt the
running backs get hurt
uh
i give kyle and that group a lot of a
lot of credit with what's
gone on up there because you're right
after that night against indianapolis
in the rain in san francisco i thought
this team is
this team just doesn't look right and
and this team's in a tough division with
arizona
and the rams and who knew what seattle
was going to be at that particular point
even though they faded
but when i see
i see them now yeah i mean you know
garoppolo is playing well kittle's a
monster he's sure he's just a monster
what he did in
in that cincinnati game that catch he
made you know going high in the air and
here's a guy coming off an injury he's
tremendous and i mean you think about
that this team and and the bad breaks
they had last year and then this year
they started out with you know rahim
mostly it's one of the best backs in the
league
lose him before the season starts
losing just about everybody took uh ayuk
a little while to get back into the flow
of things samuel is terrific we know
that
you know everybody's got problems with
the line with injuries and all of that
they've been able to work through that
so um i look at that tim i think it's
gonna be a lot of fun i think you know
heading down the stretch
in a week
a week it sounds funny week 18 because
they go to 17 games this year plus dubai
right so we we get we're going to get
the last game of the year
on that sunday night and what the league
obviously wants to do is give us a game
where you know the winner is in the
loser is out
so if we can't find that i'm looking at
the schedule that week and i know the
49ers play at the ramp yes indeed and
that that may not be winner and loser
out but that could be for you know for
for seating yeah i know i was literally
out i literally was about to finish up
our conversation by asking you what your
you know your 256 might be your game 256
or what it used to be whatever the heck
it now is now i guess you got to add you
got to add 16
game 272 right now right so right um so
uh i because i know you and uh fred
godelli jurassic off and everybody else
you know and chris talk about this stuff
in advance certainly when all you got to
do might take a courtesy car i know
you're definitely keenly interested in
that so um you put it you put it all
together that might be for the division
for the rams or the cardinals or
or or or seating which is crucially
important i i wouldn't want to face
deniers right now period yeah i mean
that's a game i mean that has to be in
the mix when you look at it from right
from this vantage point but again the
best scenario we could have and we've
had it a couple of times uh didn't have
it last year was was the winners and the
losers out right i mean that's that's
the you know that's the the golden game
right they try to get as game number
272. last year that didn't happen
remember last year we we had washington
against philadelphia
and philly was out
but washington needed to win
and they did and that's the night of
course that you know they put nate
sutfield in the game in place of jalen
hurts
and you know everybody was so angry
because the giants had a chance to get
in and and and people wanted to know you
know what in the what in the world are
you doing putting shut to take a look at
sunfilter right on that roster
three or four years and i you know
frankly you know speaking of doug
peterson is all over the conversation
we're having today
that may have sealed doug's fate last
year i know that
uh jeff lurie was not very happy about
what happened that night and and they
were embarrassed and people were saying
you know what what in the hell are you
doing you know you owe it to
every other team to uh you know to give
it your best and they had the lead at
one point two in that game and uh then
they put shutfield in and it was a
disaster and and uh washington wound up
going to the playoffs i got two for you
right here i'll send you on into your
wednesday now with two possibilities of
of winner and loser goes home because
i'm just looking at 18. here's two of
them chargers at raiders that's entirely
possible interesting chargers should be
in by then though correct fake right i
know that that's that's that
that's a that's a these are long shots i
mean right but here's one that's not so
shabby because the way how tight is
everything in the afc north and i know
you'd be all over this signing up for
another steelers ravens where loser
winner winner and loser goes home that's
a possibility right there that's right i
think i heard you say earlier that
you may have only one team from that
division because it's so tight right
going to the player so it's you know but
you can't forget cincinnati obviously
there of course they're currently in the
spot
but uh you're right i mean the way
things are going right now
rich as i've always said
nobody knows anything
and i am now i'm now changing that to
everybody knows nothing
you're workshopping it al i appreciate
it thanks for the call best to linda
have a great holiday and governor
gregory thank you susie take care of you
thanks bud you got it that's uh
michael's everybody hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here